[Música]
mi nombre es victoria alonso y junto con
kevin faith y con lüthi expósito somos
el trío con poder decisivo de los
estudios de mago en los últimos 11 años
hemos producido 23 películas que han
recaudado 22 puntos 6 billones de
dólares
hemos cambiado la historia del cine en
cierta manera hemos cambiado como
hollywood ve a los superhéroes y de esa
manera hemos cambiado como el mundo ve a
los superhéroes pero confesión aquí en
córdoba a mí no me gustan los
superhéroes
entonces se preguntarán por qué eso
trabajo de 16 a 18 horas por día 6 y 7
días a la semana
362 días al año de los 14 años que he
estado en la compañía
a los 19 años me fui de la argentina- yo
soy platense con una valija y un sueño y
le dije a mi madre que me iba a ir a
eeuu a hacer películas y a contar
historias
así fue
fui a la universidad estudié psicología
de estudio teatro y cuando termine con
mi carrera universitaria decidí que iba
a ser actriz porque era lo único que
sabía que la gente podría ser en el
teatro
que son muy altas que son muy bajas que
son muy gordas que eso es muy flaca que
sos sos latina no pareces latina que
tienes acento no pero disculpe usted no
tiene acento señorita ok quien decide
esas cosas esa fue la primera pregunta
que yo hice después de seis meses que me
rechazaron y me rechazaron y me rechazó
los productores
hay vados voy a ser productor origen
porque al fin y al cabo me di cuenta que
yo no quería ser actriz yo lo que quería
era contar historias que valiese en la
pena ser contadas pero tener poder
decisivo para hacerlas hice muchísimos
trabajos trabajos que quise hacer y
trabajos que no quise hacer
durante 15 años de carrera antes de que
yo fuera a trabajar a mago trabaje por
todas partes del mundo
yendo de un país al otro tipo parte del
circo que es ser parte de una afirmación
y llegó un momento que dije ya no quiero
volar más no quiero viajar más quiero
estar en los ángeles y de ahí que viene
la película de harman estaba trabajando
con luz y expósito en otra en otra
compañía me dijo voy a hacer esta
película donde filma en los ángeles
vamos no vamos a otro lado me quedo en
casa no porque me gustas en los
superhéroes por que filmaba en mi casa
hicimos la película y una vez que
terminó la película que ven nos pide a
lu ya mí qué forma hacemos parte del
estudio
lo primero que yo dije es no a mí no me
gusta ser de estudio no quiero ser
ejecutiva no me interesa ser parte de
eso yo quiero ser parte del grupo que
produce las películas que valen la pena
contarse pero
si me dejas de estructurar lo de una
manera y me dejas producir las películas
lo hacemos juntos porque me di cuenta
que estábamos haciendo algo diferente al
final de nuestra película si ustedes no
la vieron no tendrían que estar acá
pero le voy a decir algo bueno si son
chiquitos va bien si al final de la
película tony stark revela a un grupo de
periodistas
yo soy germain
los tiramos a los superhéroes del altar
les sacamos el velo la cosa que el resto
del mundo de los superhéroes venían
haciendo escondiéndose en nuestra primer
película nosotros lo hicimos diferente y
me di cuenta de que quizás podríamos
crear un cambio hemos hecho muchísimos
cambios en forma de
el hecho de que iron man dijera quién es
de que revela de que se burla de sí
mismo por ser un bruto capitán américa y
el escudo tirado un roto al lado de tony
stark una locura porque el escudo es lo
que lo hace el capitán américa
fort pero empecemos le cortamos el pelo
le sacamos el martillo engordamos
sigue siendo un dios
nunca lo vamos a negar pero me di cuenta
que estábamos haciendo algo diferente y
entretener cosas que eran diferentes en
una película y llegar a tener una gran
diferencia de películas como por ejemplo
black cáncer y capitán amargo dos de los
pilares que he dicho a través de los
meses de hacer prensa que es el legado
que yo le dejo a mi hija son columnas en
donde en cierto momento dijimos algo a
nivel cultural estas son dos películas
que nos dijeron constantemente el mundo
entero no son películas que el mundo
quiere ver no van a tener ningún tipo de
éxito fiscal el mundo no está preparado
para ver un héroe negro un elenco negro
dirigida por un director negro no lo van
a ver el mundo no quiere ver una mujer
protagónica no quiere que lo dirija una
mujer no quiere que lo escriba una mujer
no quiere que lo produzca una mujer
y para nosotros
si era lo último que hacíamos
era una buena salida
y decidimos que lo íbamos a hacer
combinadas esas dos historias a nivel
fiscal
recaudaron 2.5 billones de dólares
black panther fue la película que nos
dijeron que no podíamos hacer nominada
por 7 of cars 1 como la mejor película
al oscar nunca en la historia de la
academia habían tenido una película de
un superhéroe
- un superhéroe negro nominada como
mejor película
el no de algunos es el sí del otro
y en momentos en donde uno se da cuenta
de que quizás puede crear un cambio tres
historias que quería compartir con
ustedes en cierta manera de que me han
marcado de una manera muy especial y por
la gran razón en la que yo trabajo 16 18
horas por día
cuando presentamos la cantera fuimos a
un lugar que se llama comic-con que
queda en san diego algunos de ustedes lo
saben y otros no es una conferencia muy
grande donde van todas la gente a la
gente que es sumamente fanática y hay
7.000 personas que esperan 23 días
afuera para entrar y ver nuestra
presentación ryan google
el director hacía dos años que había
sido parte de la audiencia en ese
momento él a menos de 30 años creo que
tenía 28 subía el escenario para
presentar a black panther a su elenco
entero
africano o afroamericano con solamente
dos personajes blancos una cosa nunca
nunca vista
que estaba en el escenario y yo
estábamos sentados 15 butacas para atrás
y una señora venía caminando corriendo
acercándose al escenario
constantemente seguridad tratando de que
no pasara de que no pasara de no pasar a
la reconoce a mí y lo reconoce a luz yo
le digo deje la la señora estaba
temblando y lloriqueando no estaba
sentada estaba medio hincada al lado mío
temblando
cuando terminamos de hacer la
presentación una erupción total de las
siete mil personas y la señora que me
mira
llorando en ese momento completamente de
una manera que nadie nadie había llorado
al lado mío me dijo te agradezco tanto
me pasa en mi vida entera esperando a
ver a mi gente como realeza y no como
esclavo o criminal
historias que valen la pena contarlas
otra de las grandes historias para mí
fue cuando salió black antes después de
tres semanas fui a la escuela de mi hija
y una mamá que me vio y vino al patio
yo esperando que viniera mi hija me dice
te puedo decir algo y como madre ustedes
saben en el momento pensé que hizo que
no hizo con quien se peleó a quien le
tengo que pedir perdón que es ay
contame qué pasó
te quiero agradecer por haber hecho la
película de black canta
por supuesto y yo de chusma digo cuántas
veces la vio la señora de 42 43 años
afroamericana también
yo la vi cuatro veces me dijo
no se olviden que eso no es la gente que
va a ver no por lo general de 18 o 25
años y son varones la que van a ver
nuestras películas entonces la pregunta
por qué
la primera vez la fui a ver sola
la segunda vez fui con mi marido y con
mis tres hijos la tercera vez volví con
mi familia y la cuarta vez tuve un día
de porquería
y decidí ir a sentarme por dos horas
para sentir la armonía de no estar en un
mundo colonizado
historias que valen la pena contarlas
y la última historia que tengo es de un
nene de 10 años su papá nos mandó uno de
los primeros mails que recibimos cuando
terminamos con ayer me an
manda un email que nos llega luz que
venía a mí y nos dice mi bebé de 10 años
tiene que usar muchas partes de metal
porque no tiene una pierna y no tiene un
brazo y constantemente es una lucha para
el ir a la escuela
se burlan tiene dificultades todas las
mañanas es un momento para nosotros
fueron a verme
y el lunes se levante le dice papá vamos
a la escuela el papá dice que cambió que
pasó y es buena ver contarme que tenéis
muchas gracias a la escuela qué pasó si
ayer me puede tener todo todo ese metal
para volar yo puedo ir caminando la
escuela
historias que valen la pena contarlas
hemos creado muchos cambios
hemos dado vuelta al mundo en cierta
manera de como los superhéroes son
vistos y como la gente nos ha recibido
parte de yo haber dicho que no quería
volar más que no quería viajar más me ha
dado el regalo del mejor viaje de mi
vida
mi nombre es victoria alonso junto con
kevin feige y lüthi expósito hemos
producido 23 películas que han cambiado
como la gente ve a los superhéroes
soy una mujer en un mundo masculino
soy extranjera en hollywood
soy gay soy madre pero más importante
que nada soy argentina
y para que sepan por qué trabajo tantas
horas si a mí no me gustan los
superhéroes es para que cuando yo vaya
al patio de una escuela o vea un nene
que quiere ir a la escuela por haber
visto nuestras películas nos demos
cuenta que a veces los superhéroes
existen en nuestras vidas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]